a ballot initiative in front of voters
in november would change how our
elections are run in nevada it would
create an open primary and ranked choice
voting so how does that work here's a
quick explainer
first it creates an open primary meaning
you can vote for anyone on the ticket
right now you can only vote for
republicans if you're republican or
democrats if you're a democrat
the top five would then go on to the
general election in the general election
you would rank them one through five if
someone gets more than 50 percent in the
general election they win if no one gets
50 percent it goes to an instant runoff
the candidate with the fewest votes gets
eliminated their second choice gets
their votes and that continues until
someone has 50 percent
senator sandra cosgrove from better vote
nevada sat down with me to explain why
she and the group votes better votes
nevada thinks this initiative is
necessary
one of the challenges i think that some
have suggested with elections and one of
the reasons nevada democrats went to the
primary instead of the caucus for
example
confusion and just trying to make it
easier for voters to choose who they
want would you say your
what you're describing makes it easier
i would think so because we're giving us
a streamlined ballot you're not having
to worry how my register vote you're
just registered to vote we're going to
treat you the same way as every other
registered voter one ballot and then
we're allowing you to be strategic in
the general election not the political
parties
but technically you only have to pick
one you can say one
what is the um
what is the challenge that you've found
with the better votes nevada
organization and the initiative here to
get this through just finally got
through the state supreme court now so
what is next
how soon might this actually
be uh take effect so we had to turn in
141 000 signatures because with the
ballot initiative you have to go out and
talk to nevadans because that's what
initiative's supposed to do and then if
they say that sounds good to me they
sign we turned in
266 000 signatures so when we were
talking to people and gave them the
explanation i just gave you they said
let me sign that so we know we already
have a lot of support
the problem is is that the democratic
party sued us in court because they
didn't want to change things and
political parties like the status quo
and so that's not surprising to us the
nevada supreme court ruled in our favor
now what we need to do is do exactly
what i'm doing right now is get the word
out we prevailed we had enough
signatures you know we're going to be on
the ballot in november we need people to
vote yes
is there a benefit to going i'm not
saying it's exactly the same i
acknowledge that right but just having
more people involved in the electoral
process for longer beyond the price yes
yes we want and our turnout for this
primary in clark county was 23 percent
that's not consensus we want more people
being engaged so we're we're looking at
again different countries that use this
process alaska is using it right now
maine has been using it they do have
more people showing up because now my
candidate made it through because what
we we see is that if your candidate
doesn't make it through the primary
you're like well i didn't like those two
what do i care now if your candidate
made it through you're more likely to be
engaged and candidates are more likely
to say all right i was number five i'm
probably not going to win i know you're
number one
i have voters that really like me if you
would maybe take one of my ideas i could
tell my voters to make you their number
two but isn't the whole idea of the
primary to
sort of
sort that out so that at the general
election you have you can at the end of
the day find consensus versus keeping a
whole bunch of candidates strung along
through until the general election
so a lot of people will tell you the
purpose of a primary is to pick the
nominees for the political parties that
is not true
if you again the nonpartisan races
if somebody gets 50 plus one in the
nonpartisan race they just got elected
we now have a new sheriff right right so
we're not using the primaries for that
but even in the partisan races there was
a law passed in 2015 it's sb 499 and it
says if only one party
fields candidates in a partisan election
whoever wins in that closed primary is
the candidate
and so we are electing people even in
the closed primary and so what we're
saying is is we think the political
parties are controlling the primary too
much
and we want to have more people being
able to participate we want more
candidates to also go forward because
two you know we've got 1.7 million
voters in clark county two people are
actually going to represent that we
don't think so
if you want to know more about the
initiative it's a lot to digest we can
watch the full interview there on
8newsnow.com